[Music]
it's supposed to be a suicide you
dumbbell you didn't tell him to leave
the G I don't know why I told him to
leave the gun I told him told him to
leave the gun just like you told him I
don't know why he didn't I don't know
why I told him just like you told him
you told him to do it in the front of
the head and why did he do it in the
back of the head it's so simple the
front is the front the back is the back
man he has to make it looky like he done
himself it just looks like murder it's
not supposed to be that way you hear her
I told him the front of the head I said
the front of the head just like this
just like you told me I I promise you I
promise you I swear on my children I
swear on my children
K and don't swear on your children makes
you look foolish well I ain't I ain't
foolish cuz
I whose land is
this my
land well well well our war hero has
arrived you made a good choice coming
back here says are the finest wealthiest
and most beautiful people on God's Earth
yeah smart
everybody they have the say who gets the
oil son I got a question you like women
that's my
weakness well we mix these families
together and that estate money flows the
right direction it will come to us
SOI that's how you are I don't know what
you said but must have been Indian for
handsome devil
[Music]
why did you come
here I work with my uncle you scared of
him oh he's a he's the nicest man in the
world the old sieg their time is over we
got to take back control of her
home I sent down from Washington DC to
see about these
murders we have so many deaths we've
lost count it's just bad luck seems more
like an epidemic than bad luck to
me those say just dying by the enemy do
not let them die
alone evil surrounds my
heart you going to pick a
side I don't even know if you L me
anymore of course I'm love you and kill
these men who killed my
family did you wife say who she was most
afraid
[Applause]
of don't do something you're going to
regret for the rest of your
[Music]
life I ain't got nothing but
regret
[Music]
go